[Music]
even working television obviously with
great success for number of years you've
made this you made a movie
what's more draining what's more
difficult that's it's good quit you know
the movie that's a good question
you know we the movie was very very
draining the movie was super training
yeah I mean there it's time to get
halfway through the run you like we got
to go do another day and this this guy
here you got you got particularly drain
on one day so okay let me set I'll set
this little story up we look good we had
one scene that ended up getting cut from
the film because it was as a serie and
not funny but in the movie my character
gets a finds a kitten and that's like
the heart of the movie I love this
kitten and and the kitten gets stolen
and we have this scene where we wake up
I'm he wakes up and I'm sitting there
and I'm having my life fondant yeah it's
my dramatic moment it's like leave the
weapon inside and he comes over to me
and your line is something like you know
that hey you know it's gonna be okay
let's go let's go find your cat okay you
know something like turning point in a
movie let's go find the cat the movies
all about exactly right and so what
happens is I'm laying on a couch this is
after three weeks of shooting and I'm
laying on a couch so you can let me kick
you back okay so you might you'll be my
that you're alright so I'm on the couch
I'm on the couch and I'm asleep like I'm
asleep you know I'm like this is bad
news because I'm sleeping in the scene
and so we were all action I'll be the
directors voice and I'm sitting here and
then Peter goes our director or director
goes and action
[Music]
action
[Music]
finally finally Peter Peter goes
Keagan action and you see you gotta get
the cat
[Applause]
you